you're a senior manager at a global firm
and you're about to sign an important
deal with a Chinese company on your
flight to cook after your flight to
Guangzhou
the officials greet you and they invite
you over for dinner
here is what could happen to you the
English believe it's a slur on your
hosts food if you don't clear your plate
whereas the Chinese feel you're
questioning their generosity if you do
okay at HSBC we'll never underestimate
the importance of local knowledge okay
it'd just be C the world's local bank
but here is another story of how
cultures miscommunication led to a
devastating consequence in 1945 near the
end of World War two
the winning allies issued a declaration
to call for Japan's unconditional
surrender the Japanese Prime Minister
when questioned by the journalists
mumbled this single word more Kusatsu
now this has several different meanings
in Japan depending on the context what
he meant was withholding comment and so
he makes a final decision the allies
interpretation however refusal within
days
Hiroshima was bombed now this was an
extreme example but think about this
even within this room of 47 students we
represent 19 countries
that's 19 different styles of
communication just imagine when you go
out into the world the diversity of
cultures you may encounter you may be
selling a product to German companies
you may be negotiating with Brazilians
and you may be working for a Chinese CEO
so that's why today we'd like to
introduce the three
as of global communication to be aware
adapt and acknowledge the cultural
differences culture and the pins a lot
of social norms and expectations of how
to behave culture is also very relative
and it is also not homogeneous so in the
larger society
there can be smaller groups within the
culture within the society which are
very different culture from the bigger
society so having an understanding and
being aware of the different dimensions
of culture will help us become more
sensitive to the different groups that
we work with in the different countries
that we may live in we are participating
activities really this is a framework
they were adapted from professor
Hofstede and he sees we see four
dimensions of culture power distance
diagram indirect individualism
short-term versus long-term orientation
how this dance is really about hierarchy
is it flat or is it a pyramid is the
leader the first among equals or is he
the king on the throne I've worked in
many organizations with very different
cultures and every time I need to
organize a meeting I always need to
think about how to sit people how to
arrange people is it in a circle or is
it by order of seniority and hierarchy
direct versus indirect direct cultures
tend to be very tough to enter very
verbal very explicit in the way they
communicate indirect cultures on the
other hand rely a lot more on context
nonverbal cues implicit information to
complete the message so it really is a
great example of a very direct culture
one of our classmates showed us there is
release our more direct than Americans
they say they say as it is no
sugarcoating individualism versus
collectivism the question the thing
about is the individual the pivotal unit
in a group or is
the group and the society and a culture
encouraging the person to be conforming
and to be independent of others in
individualistic societies and cultures
it is very important to voice your own
opinion I think Stanford is a great
example in Stanford we are encouraged to
think critically to challenge the
question and I'm sure many of you would
have questioned the instructors the
lecturers and the guest lecturers that
walked through our classrooms the last
one is short-term versus long-term
gratification orientation are we looking
for the here and now are we thinking
about a partnership towards a longer
term are we looking for quick results
instant gratification or are we thinking
about building something a little bit
for the long term and thinking about the
long term outcomes in cultures with long
term orientation some companies may put
emphasis on arrangements that benefit
the longer term relationship and the
longer term partnership and this could
possibly come at the expense of
near-term results so now that we're
aware of some of the differences across
cultures let's talk about some of the
ways that we can adapt our own
communication first eye contact eye
contact is a great way to connect with
your audience but it can also be tricky
in cultures where power distance is high
holding eye contact could be seen as a
challenge to Authority and when you look
at someone they might look down or look
away simply out of politeness or respect
we've learned in this class to try and
make eye contact throughout your
audience but in a hierarchical culture
they might expect you to spend a little
more focus and attention on those in
positions of authority in a collectivist
culture eye contact could make people
feel a little bit uneasy because you're
effectively singling them out from the
crowd if I were to hold eye contact with
someone for the recommended 5 to 7
seconds like I'm doing right now with
Natalie's it could become extremely
painful for that person
our contact can still be an effective
tool but keep in mind that what feels
right for you might end up feeling
offensive or uncomfortable for someone
else gestures can also be a powerful
communication tool but remember that
different cultures have different levels
of expressiveness
in a collectivist culture you'd be
unlikely to see someone with a very
animated high energy style because again
that would single them out from the
crowd so if that happens to be your
style you may consider dialing it back
just a little bit in addition some
gestures that are common in the u.s. can
be quite offensive in other countries so
before you tell your audience that
things are going great with an
enthusiastic thumbs up you may want to
consider anyone in your audience who's
from Greece who you'd effectively be
telling up yours
as far as directness in this class we
learn to use the inverted pyramid
structure that is to start with your
main idea and then add supporting
details in the US we appreciate this
direct approach and getting to the point
but that approach might not work in
other countries in Japan for example it
would be common to see a work email that
might start by saying something like now
it is autumn and the delicate red leaves
are blanketing the cool earth with color
try starting your work emails in the US
with some poetic prose about the seasons
people are probably gonna think you're a
little weird but in other countries it
would be perfectly normal and expected
to spend a little more time and effort
upfront to nurture the relationship and
you risk coming across as all business
with a u.s. style approach when it comes
to writing we learn to use strong verbs
active voice clear language but in
cultures that value in directness
passive voice and ambiguous words might
actually be preferred
now we're really only scratching the
surface here we reached out to many of
you and asked if there was anything we
learned in class that might not go so
well in your home country or in places
where you worked we learned that in
Nigeria speaking above your normal voice
level could actually be considered rude
we learned that in Mexico a presentation
that might be considered normal in the
US could come across as exaggerated or
over-the-top in both style and content
we learned that in Latin America or in
Kenya and other parts of Africa work
emails are still expected to have very
formal language and interestingly we
learned that in Bulgaria people actually
shake their head to say yes and nod
their head to say no which would be
incredibly confusing as you can imagine
so as you can see there are many
different ways that cultural principles
apply across the world but it's
important to remember that the
overarching strategy remains the same
which is to know your audience know your
intent and know your message thank you
Tim so I imagine that a few of you might
feel a bit frustrated right now right
after a whole quarter of strategic
communication where you're just thinking
I think I kind of got it now we are just
pulling the rug from beneath you and now
you might feel man how can I possibly
keep track of all these different
cultures and now you know what I'm a
little worried that I might mess up is
one in here that might relate to that
feeling show of hands guy like that and
you know what throw those most of you
who raised your hand I I think you have
a point like I agree with you because
the reality is that most of us in this
room as far as I know aren't chameleons
right we're not going to seamlessly
blend in and perfectly adapt to any
social cultural context we're humans and
that means that sooner or later we are
going to mess up and you know what
that's okay because we have a secret
little weapon here today and that ladies
and gentlemen is our third and last day
of the day acknowledgement if you're in
a situation in which you feel like there
might be a cultural mismatch simply
acknowledging that fact can be hugely
powerful and I'll show you what I mean
all right something like this I'm aware
that things are done differently here
then where I'm from right so please
excuse me and let me know if I do or say
something inappropriate now of course
you don't have to use that exact
sentence but there are a couple of
things I'd like to highlight that are
going on there first of all I'm saying
you know what I know there are
differences
and the truth is that your audience
might be just as anxious a tapping rude
towards you as you are as appearing rude
towards them and just simply
acknowledging those differences can help
everyone relax a bit and focus on the
things you have in common
rather than those differences second I'm
apologizing in advance for any mistakes
I might do right so I'm first of all
showing respect but I'm also giving
myself carte blanche to keep on moving
in my presentation even if I do a little
mistake here in there last I'm asking
for feedback which shows that I'm trying
to learn and to improve what this also
does that it overcomes the fact that in
many situations many audiences in
certain cultures especially might be
just too polite to tell you even if
you're doing something wrong again and
again and again and again so most of all
what acknowledgement does is that it
lets you stop worrying too much about
messing up about stepping on toes and
unless you focus on the message you were
there to deliver in the first place
right and that's really what matters and
so now I think you know the secret next
time you're on the road to deliver to go
to business meeting deliver presentation
in a new country or continent remember
that you have the triples a triple A's
of global communication to help you so a
aware do your research
a adapt try to respect and emulate and
they acknowledge address those
differences now I want to thank you all
for listening and we'd love to answer
questions about how you can best use the
Triple A method over here to become a
more sensitive global communicator